on
[Musique]
ce sont les derniers moments d'un long
voyage qui touche à sa fin
evelyne ne pensais pas revenir si tôt
dans son pays
les philippines
[Musique]
à quelques minutes de l'atterrissage
elle découvre déjà à travers la petite
fenêtre du hublot
c'est qu'au dévastée
huit jours après le passage du typhon
qui a ravagé une partie de l'archipel
elle est toujours sans nouvelles de sa
famille
[Musique]
elle espère retrouver son fils léandro
sa belle fille l'avait n'ya et ses trois
petits enfants
tiny cinq ans qu'à lille 3 en écaille
un bébé de 6 mois
sur le tarmac cela ressemble à une zone
de guerre
après avoir bouclé 11000 km depuis paris
évelyne est désormais en première ligne
dès la descente de l'avion elle assiste
aux retrouvailles d'autres familles
son rêve a elle aussi
sur la piste à quelques mètres d'elle
les files d'attentes de ceux qui
préfèrent fuir la région en avion
militaire ne cesse de s'allonger
c'est très compliqué c'est n'importe
quoi
malgré la désorganisation evelyne
parvient à récupérer ses bagages parmi
les premiers elle ne s'attardera pas
il reste encore onze kilomètres à
parcourir pour rejoindre sa ville natale
palau l'a été
à paris nous avons rencontré evelyne la
veille de son départ chez elle cloîtré
dans sa chambre de bonne
depuis le passage du typhon impossible
pour elle de rester 24 heures de plus
devant son ordinateur a échangé avec son
fils aîné
tous deux un puissant dans la tente d'un
hypothétique message du jeune léandro je
n'ai pas de nouvelles s
mais non plus et c'est ça qui nous
inquiète et je ne peux pas lui dire quoi
que ce soit parce que je ne sais rien on
tôt alors elle a décidé de partir pour
tacle au ban la valise pleine de
médicaments grâce à toutes ses amies
philippines de paris elle sait que
là-bas on manque de tout cela fait dix
ans kevin travail à paris en tant
qu'aide à domicile pour personnes âgées
le choix d'une vie loin des siens pour
offrir un meilleur avenir à ses fils aux
philippines à 49 ans elle pensait avoir
tout planifié tout sauf le typhon avait
quatre jeunes arrivent pas cela est bien
dormir je n'arrête pas d'y penser
j'arrive pas à travailler ni à manger ce
que je sais qu'ils ont faim même si
c'est dangereux dnd 0
peu importe les risques le pire est de
ne pas savoir
j'ai envie de me dire qu'ils vont bien
mais je ne vais pas vous mentir doit
affronter la vérité que c'est le moment
d'affronter la réalité et de l'accepter
quoi qu'est le real
elle sait qu'elle ne pourra compter que
sur elles pour mener les recherches
[Musique]
le lendemain matin et flynn s'apprête à
rejoindre l'aéroport
[Musique]
ses amis philippins ont collecté 200
euros pour participer aux frais de son
voyage en les nerfs tout compris pour
aller aux philippines
ça m'a coûté 1000 euros et je ne gagne
que le smic
j'ai dépensé beaucoup d'argent ce mois
ci c'est énorme pour moi
de paris à hong kong de hong kong à
manille evelyne n'est pas revenu dans
son pays depuis le mariage de son fils
l'été dernier
elle est pressée de retrouver sa terre
natale qu'elle craint de ne pas
reconnaître
elle est comme des milliers de
philippins qui sont déjà à la recherche
de leurs proches
voilà ce qu'est bling va bientôt
découvrir sur cette route qui traverse
le district de tacles au ban
il ne reste plus rien debout
c'est là que nous croisons judeline elle
a 20 ans sans nouvelles de son père et
de sa mère depuis 11 jours elle ne vient
pas de paris pourtant elle vit juste de
l'autre côté de la baie la voix vient à
peine d'être déblayée
aujourd'hui il a laissé ses deux enfants
pour essayer de retrouver ses parents
c'est à moto qu'elle va pouvoir entamer
ses recherches
après des jours de pénurie l'essence est
revenu à prix d'or manon est ce que je
peux venir les bouts jusqu'à san josé
c'est combien trajet trois cent 300 300
pesos philippins soit 5 euros
ces trois fois le prix normal du délit
n'a pas le choix
sandro c est encore loin
il faut une heure pour parcourir 10 km
se met deux cadavres dans des sacs noirs
obligation de descendre de motos à
maintes reprises
c'est une route traque les cette jeune
femme qui a grandi ici ne reconnaît plus
rien bah oui c'est grave
il n'y a plus de maison il n'y a plus
rien même les rues tous les chemins sont
détruits avant c'était très joli ici
viennent maintenant il n'y a plus des
déchets
ah ben oui quoi là-bas s'est-elle
oriental hotel il est complètement
détruit c'était le plus connu tous les
touristes y allait à yohann gagné à
l'été c'est tout ce qu'il reste de
l'hôtel autrefois un complexe de luxe
sur 10 hectares 110 chambres vue sur mer
balayé en une journée
[Musique]
sous ses yeux
son quartier natal de sandro c c'est
terrible il ya plus de maisons sans
procès n'est plus qu'une vaste plaine
sumann et les niveaux là c'est ici
qu'habitent ma mère c'est l'un des
quartiers les plus touchés
jamais elle n'aurait pu imaginer ça ça
me donne envie de pleurer de voir ça je
me demande si mes parents mes frères et
soeurs sont encore en vie jeu de lille
n'arrive pas à se repérer manon
messieurs ils étaient où le terrain
basket
je cherche le terrain de basket
[Musique]
des minutes d'errance entre les corps au
avant de se rendre à l'évidence allez
ligne lala c'est là c'est la maison des
parents
ou pas
[Musique]
bah oui mais c'est tout à n'a pas moi
mappy c'est tout ce qu'il reste de sa
maison il n'ya plus que la dalle les
affaires de toute une famille tiennent
dans cette petite boîte en boîte
[Musique]
gore mon dieu j'espère juste qu'ils sont
en vie même s'il n'y a plus de maison
que leur est-il arrivé
où sont-ils judeline devra se
débrouiller seuls pour les retrouver
[Musique]
après 18 heures d'avion deux escales
depuis paris et bly n'arrive attaque
loban pendant son voyage elle a reçu un
message d'un ami sa famille seraient en
vie un espoir fou ce sont les derniers
kilomètres avant le terminus la ville de
palo les plus durs c'est très triste
c'est un désert c'est la première fois
que je vois mon pays dans cet état dans
quelle situation vie son fils et sa
famille leurs maisons at-elle résisté
[Musique]
la réponse à ces questions
et au bout de cette rue
[Musique]
elle attendait ça depuis une semaine
serrer ses petits enfants dans les bras
evelyne la grand mère retrouve le
sourire
toute la famille est en bonne santé et
kayes la petite dernière de six mois
elle non plus n'a pas souffert léandro
lui encore troublé préfère rester en
retrait commence à mano qui est fait
pour toi
rose je retrouve ma famille mes enfants
mes petits enfants
on va pouvoir démarrer une nouvelle vie
[Musique]
une autre bonne surprise l'attend à
l'extérieur
c'est hélène l'autre grand mère sa
meilleure amie aussi elle a tenu à
accueillir yvelines j'étais tellement
inquiète ce matin là je me suis dit mon
dieu
le vent était tellement fort mais
c'était comme une tornade le vent allait
d'un côté puis souffler de l'autre très
fort s'est mis à tourner comme ça une
tornade la masse du cyclone s'est
abattue dès les premières heures de ce
vendredi 8 novembre
des rafales de vent d'abord d'une force
inouïe
[Musique]
plus de 360 km heure
des pluies diluviennes ensuite
et puis la mer se déchaîne des vagues de
5 mètres de haut
l'océan montrent même les escaliers le
piège et yann s'est refermé sur des
milliers de personnes la nuit est tombée
à palau une nouvelle nuit noire privés
d'électricité seuls les feux est clair
les rues evelyne et sa famille ne se
risque pas à l'extérieur bien longtemps
de peur des agressions
c'est encore un peu tôt pour rentrer à
la maison mais en ce moment dès qu'il
fait nuit personne est autorisée à
rester dehors
pour des raisons de sécurité le
couvre-feu imposé par les autorités est
fixé à 19 heures précises dans la maison
le dîner se prépare déjà au menu ce soir
quelques morceaux de boeuf du riz et
quelques pommes de terre sur ce barbecue
de fortune
on fait ce qu'on peut en ce moment
quelque part j'ai besoin de sourire
c'est typique des philippins même si
nous faisons face à de gros problèmes
on garde le sourire la famille d'evelyne
vie sur les réserves de provisions
faites dès les premières alertes aux
typhons de la prévoyance
et de la chance aussi leur maison est
aujourd'hui la plus grande encore debout
dans le quartier ils ont même ouvert
leurs portes à leurs plus proches
voisins c'est mon lit et au premier
étage c'est pour notre famille est ici
juste à côté on a eu notre famille nos
voisins les plus proches amis et madame
balthazar et ses deux fils
et pourquoi sont ils là ils n'ont plus
de maison et ils n'ont plus d'endroit
pour dormir
nous sommes là depuis plus d'une semaine
et peut-être que nous allons rester deux
ou trois semaines supplémentaires parce
qu'il n'y a personne pour réparer le
toit de notre maison
les ouvriers en ce moment ne sont pas
disponibles
vous savez ils sont en train de réparer
leurs propres maisons
il faudra sans doute se serrer les
coudes encore longtemps
comme chaque jour depuis le passage du
typhon
palau se réveille au son des grues des
marteaux c'est une vie à reconstruire
sur les décombres
[Musique]
après la joie d'avoir retrouvé ses
proches
evelyne découvre une autre réalité celle
est il ouvre les yeux rue après rue dans
ce quartier avait pour habitude de faire
leurs courses
de ce côté il y avait des points sonel
jaune et de l'autre à dubaï doit ça où
il y avait débouché dans cette allée il
ne reste plus qu'un seul vendeur les
rations sont maigres
un peu de viande quelques légumes et de
l'huile vendu dans des petits sachets
plastiques 20 pesos avant le typhon pour
ce prix là on avait introduit là c'est
horrible c'est tellement cher mais pas
moyen de négocier pour trouver de quoi
manger il faut sillonner les quartiers à
la recherche des vendeurs ambulants plus
conciliant evelyne et hélène veulent de
la viande pour le repas du soir
peut-être des poulets
combien ça coûte 120 pesos avant c'était
combien 120 ça a toujours été 120 ce
sont des gens bien eux au moins ils
n'essayent pas de faire monter les prix
ceux qui n'ont plus rien en revanche ne
peuvent compter que sur l'aide
alimentaire
venu du ciel
deux millions et demi de personnes
dépendent de ces hélicoptères de l'armée
américaine notamment
il achemine plusieurs fois par jour des
vivres sur l'île de l'été
[Musique]
au sol la population doit prendre en
charge seul la répartition des rations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
et souvent c'est au plus débrouillards
[Musique]
un peu plus loin la distribution semble
mieux encadrer les files d'attentes
organisée c'est une fonctionnaire de
l'état philippin qui supervise il ya dur
il
[Musique]
des nouilles aux danses des sardines et
de l'eau minérale
il n'y en aura pas pour tout le monde
écoutez moi il faut faire la queue court
et là bas vous voyez les commentaires il
ya une autre distribution
[Musique]
ça fait onze jours que le typhon a
frappé quatre millions de personnes sont
sans abri parmi elles peut-être les
parents de jus de line nous avions
laissé la jeune femme sur la dalle de
leur maison nous la retrouvons aux
portes du plus grand centre pour
déplacer de tacles au ban
l'astronome ce palais des congrès aussi
grand qu'un stade c'était le refuge
avant le passage du typhon
des milliers de personnes y campe
toujours sans sanitaires sans hygiène
dans une odeur pestilentielle dès son
arrivée
c'est la première déconvenue aucune
personne répertoriés je n'ai plus de
nouvelles de ma famille je voudrais
savoir s'ils sont ici ils viennent de
san jose cobo ses quartiers au le
terminal on le terminal oui il y en a de
ce quartier faut faire le toit par ici
merci et personne pour la guider dans ce
dédale insalubres
mais un peu plus loin une affiche
retient son attention
une liste de numéros le décompte froid
et anonyme des personnes disparues ou
mortes par quartier ma mère habite ici
district d'un hangar 83
je regarde non sur cette ligne pas
disparu
rien non plus sur la colonne des morts
j'espère qu'elle est juste reparti d'ici
pour un autre endroit
la dernière chance c'est d'aller voir
sur son lieu de travail
gardez espoir coûte que coûte car elle
le sait cette liste n'a rien d'officiel
sa maman travaille en plein centre ville
dans un magasin de meubles à peine
traversé la rue la délivrance surgissent
en un coup d'oeil
[Musique]
et maman maman est là là au premier
étage sa petite soeur est à la fenêtre
du magasin pour jude et line ce sont les
ultimes secondes d'inquiétude après 11
jours de recherches à l'intérieur tout a
été balayé par le vent et l'eau mais
toute la famille est bien là réunis je
t'ai cherché partout
[Musique]
maman je suis allé jusque chez toi
là-bas y ait des morts
sa mère n'a pas la force de se relever
grippé épuisé à peine parvient elle à
chuchoter son périple avant le typhon on
est allé à l'astrodome toutes les
autorités nous avait dit d'y aller
pourquoi il ya eu autant de morts alors
qu'on vous avait dit d'aller à
l'astrodome beaucoup n'ont pas voulu
partir personne ne pouvait s'attendre à
des vagues aussi forte
tous les voisins sont morts heureusement
s'est retrouvé aucun être cher n'a
disparu
le soulagement d'être ensemble s'exprime
avec pudeur quand tant d'autres n'ont
pas eu cette chance
en fait on n'a plus rien
on a tout perdu on a juste sauvé nos
vies
c'est le plus important la vie est
ailleurs
il va falloir tourner le dos au chaos
dans la famille d'evelyne on échafaude
des plans pour l'avenir
léandro possédait une petite entreprise
de fabrication de bougies
mais la tempête a tout emporté sans
argent à la banque ni travail le jeune
papa sait que son destin et celui de sa
famille se dessine d'ailleurs on ne veut
pas quitter l'a été pour manille
mais la vie ici est difficile
on reviendra quand tout ira mieux
surtout pour les enfants et ils ont
besoin de quitter cet endroit parce
qu'il a trop de danger c'est la basse
j'espère que mon mari va trouver un
nouveau travail
même un petit boulot même un job dans
une ferme pour nous aider à survivre
à manille ou ailleurs pas facile pour
ces jeunes de s'imaginer loin de leurs
racines
[Musique]
quel futur peut naître de ces ruines
comment reconstruire
ils sont nombreux aujourd'hui à douter
que cela soit possible un jour